- [John] At the top of the
track right before a race,
I tell myself there's nothing I can't do.
People have died doing
this, and I know that.
But going 90 miles per
hour is so damn fun.
(soft music)
My name is John Daly,
and I'm a two time
Olympic skeleton slider.
The skeleton track is
roughly one mile long
and I'll slide up to 90 miles per hour
with my face only one inch off the ice.
You get a green light, and
you take off sprinting
and you can't hear a thing.
(heartbeat pounding)
When I make contact with the sled,
it feels like a place
I've been my whole life.
Last 15 years I've made that
same jump onto the sled.
You could feel immense pressure
as you're pulling five g's,
so my eight pound head
now weighs 40 pounds.
If you start to get stiff,
you start to get scared,
it's not gonna work; the
sled's gonna break loose on you
and you are gonna crash.
You have to embrace the speed
instead of getting afraid of it.
At the bottom of the skeleton race,
when I've had a really good run,
I feel like I could run through the wall.
You're so pumped up, and
that's why I love it.